the environment that we raise kids is so
much different than it was in times of
the past where there was a community
there was Elders grandparents Aunts
Uncles cousins there was a whole
community and so now it's you get one or
two hopefully people that are imprinting
or projecting their own patterns onto
you and what they think is good or
normal uh and in the past there used to
be 20.
yeah how big of a problem is that
well you just summarized several
chapters of my book
um so
there's a story I like to tell that I
read recently
um in my book The Myth of normal I quote
a psychologist her name is darcia narves
and she
now retired as a professor at Notre Dame
University and she studied
hunter-gatherer groups and and
Indigenous people how they parent and
they parented exactly the way you
described in communities children had
many parents I mean they knew the
biological parents and had a special
issue with them but they're really
parented by the whole community so they
felt very safe very contained
um very connected that's her that's what
evolved as human beings and we lived
that way for hundreds of thousands of
years
almost a blink of an eyeball really
um and modern society the separation is
getting worse and worse and worse
[Music]
darcia just written the new book which
will be published next year uh for which
I wrote the forward and uh
it's called the evolved nest and the
evolved Nest is the context in which we
evolved as human beings
and she Compares us to other animals so
the story that I loved in her new book
which is out next year
you know when enough and mother gives
birth you know what happens this is
incredible so when the mother elephant
goes into labor
all the other mothers stand in a circle
and when the newborn hits the ground
they all stroke the newborn with their
trunks wow so birth itself was a
communal experience wow you know and
that's certainly meant to be the latest
for human beings
so in the book I have a chapter on
prenatal experiences we know already
that stresses on pregnant women
translate into stress on the baby that
in a way that changes the baby's
physiology and brain development affects
it in negative ways in ways that we can
trace decades later now how well do we
look after pregnant women I mean as a
physician I was trained to do the blood
tests and the ultrasounds and the
physical examinations maybe talk about
nutrition nobody ever suggested that I
talked to a woman about her emotional
states and how stress she was and what
kind of supportion is eating then
there's the birth process
and again you know I delivered a lot of
babies as a physician thank God for
modern obstetrics so I'm not here to
military against the you know the
Miracles of modern medicine black we've
carried it way too far we approach Earth
as a disaster waiting to happen and we
interfere with it mechanize it and
lights and machines and noise and we're
actually interfering with the natural
process that's meant to
help the infant and the mother Bond and
with their interference we're actually
already interfering with the mother
infant Bond wow then here's the fact
that in the United States where we're
speaking right now I'm Canadian but in
the U.S here 25 of women have to go back
to work within two weeks of giving birth
but that amongst to a massive
abandonment of infants because that
infant physiologically and emotionally
needs to be with their mom for much
longer we create the separation right
from the beginning right
you get we get it wrong right from the
beginning
culture and Society just honoring
working hard and sacrificing and you
know just prioritizing everything other
than
you know children and well-being and
mental health it's all about status and
money keeping your job getting a
promotion well my friend the um I don't
know if you know his name is Rafi he's a
children's singer
um he's a real famous children's
Troubadour he's sitting at the first
Clinton inauguration and it's just a
world famous children's singer
um generations of kids have grown up
singing his songs and he was telling me
that he was laying there bed at night
maybe 10 15 years ago and all of a
sudden he he sat a bolt up right and his
thought child honoring came into his
head and he said what if Care Society
then honors children if we just ask
ourselves what does it to create a world
that honors the real needs of children
we will do everything differently yeah
the foods we sell kids the the products
that you know we wouldn't be
pushing addictive devices on them at an
early age we wouldn't be separating from
the mother is at two weeks of age
just that very question of what would it
take to create a world that honors the
needs of children
turns out
that's how Aboriginal people indigenous
people actually lived if they lived in
the way that honored children
well I know you've spoken so much about
children and
um holding them when they're crying and
yeah
um taking care of their needs
um so what is it that creates a securely
attached child
sure well I I think you told me you have
dogs is that right I do what does it
take to create a secure attachment with
a dog
I just yes I I actually just had
something come through last night that
was
just honor what they want to do honor
what they want to do if she's picking my
hand up just pet her if she drops the
ball in front of me throw the ball like
yeah those are her loves and that's
essentially her language well so so
there's certain brain circuits that we
share with all mammals including dogs
okay now
um and those brain circuits that's our
biological psychological nature they
dictate that children have certain
essential needs what I call irreducible
needs needs that if they're not met they
lead to a distorted development and and
lack of health so what are the
irreducible needs of children
they're not that different from
irreducible needs of other mountains
first of all
um an attachment relationship with
parents that's absolutely secure uh
where the child is just welcomed that
you are the person that we want
you are the person you want in this
world
secure attachment
unconditional
um
you don't have to be pretty you don't
have to be smart you don't have to be
compliant you don't have to be cute you
don't have to be clever
you're just you're the one we want
that's the first one
the second the second point is within
that relationship the child has to be
able to rest
by arrest we mean or I mean or
my psychologist friend who gave me this
concept means the child shouldn't have
to work to make the relationship work
because the relationship should be
unconditional so in a lot of homes
parents love their kids it's not a
question of do they love them but if the
parents are having stresses and problems
the child will very often take on the
responsibility of trying to make it
better by fitting in by being nice by
being compliant by suppressing their own
feelings
this is typical in homes where there's
alcoholism by the way a child could work
to make the relationship work with the
parent a child so it shouldn't need rest
where they don't have to work to make
the relationship work yeah so the third
need I have already mentioned which is
the freedom to experience all of our
emotions and be held through those
emotions a lot of parents in this
Society there's a lot of behavior
psychologists impanding so-called
experts who tell parents when the child
is angry give them a time out in other
words like you do is you threaten the
child with the loss of what's most
important to them which is that
attachment relationship and you say to
them this attachment is conditional if
you have emotions that I don't like
and if you manifest those emotions
you're going to be deprived of me which
is your biggest need
so then a child is in this dilemma okay
I'm a two-year-old frustrated little
angry little kid as kids off and I but
if I'm in my anger
my parents will reject me
that's not what the parent intends to do
but that's the effect of the time out
right
yeah so the child doesn't suppress
themselves disconnect them from
theirselves in order to maintain their
relationship so the third need is their
freedom to feel all our emotions
the fourth one is what you mentioned
about dogs we have a need to play
spontaneous fee play out there in nature
that's wired into our brains play it
turns out according to all the research
is much more important for brain
development than cognitive learning
absolutely so there's all this stuff
about Baby Einsteins and teaching kids
uh all this stuff early and you know
video games to
promote brain development it's all
nonsense what promotes brain development
is healthy spontaneous play that's why
animals play that's why your puppies
play that's why Bear Cubs play
and in our society we've almost totally
deprived kids of these spontaneous
players So when you say what it takes to
develop a healthy child meet those four
conditions and you'll have it
emotionally healthy balance connected
grounded confident child
[Music]